so thanks so first I'd like to thank the
organizers for the for the invitation to
speak what I'm going to talk about is
strong noise sensitivity and random
graphs and everything I speak about will
be joint work with Eyal lovetsky and
feel free to interrupt me anytime you
want for comments questions or whatever
ok so the outline the outline of the
talk is first I'll tell you what noise
sensitivity of boolean functions means
and then I'll describe the benjamini
kawaii shrum theorem then I'm going to
tell you a different ocean a somewhat
stronger notion called strong noise
sensitivity and this sort of just came
up in some natural way we were trying to
understand the noise sensitivity of
there any of the young erdos-renyi
random breath model which i'll remind
you of or tell you of and just in the
analysis of trying to study noise
sensitivity for it this this somehow
this notion seemed to very naturally
arise out of it and it turned out to be
a somewhat interesting and so we call
that noise sensitivity so that will be
part of the talk and then what the main
part of the talk will be to describe
noise sensitivity or sometimes strong
noise sensitivity for certain properties
involving the erdos-renyi random graph
model so let me tell you right now
although most people probably know let
me tell you right now what the
erdos-renyi random graph model does very
simple it has two parameters and in P
and it's just a random graph on n
vertices the end is for the number of
vertices and then between each pair of
vertices I simply put an edge there
independently for different pairs each
with probability P so I did a random
graph and that's called the arrow to any
random graph model which turns out to be
interesting and I'll give you some
sketch of some arguments okay so boolean
functions the noise sensitivity so what
is the basic setup
44 noise sensitivity well we have n
random variables x1 through xn there I
ID and there are 1 with probability P n
and 0 with probability 1 minus PN and a
lot of models PN will just be a half but
we allow to depend upon n in particular
in particular to the erdos-renyi random
graph model it's very important that the
pn will depend upon n okay and so we
start off with this random sequence of
coin flips and then we have a boolean
function f from 01 10 in 201 and we'll
assume this function f is going to be
non degenerate so so the probability
that F is one I mean the 01 to the end s
corresponds to the this possible
sequence sequences x1 through xn so then
I can talk about the probability that F
is one and throughout the talk we're
always going to make sure that put the
property of F is one is that F is
non-degenerate the probably F is one is
going to be bounded away 0 & 1 so Delta
is positive okay now in noise
sensitivity you do a small perturbation
of X and this perturbation is called X
sub epsilon gives you a new sequence X 1
epsilon through xn epsilon and it's the
small perturbation of X so what do we do
each X I is independently resampled with
probability epsilon so in other words to
each of x1 through xn independently I
take the bit and I decide to resample it
and resample means I cross off what it
was and I put a new thing there a one or
a zero with the probabilities pn 0 or 1
minus pn so just have a little picture
here that might might be my sequence X
and then I decide each one independently
epsilon is very small I resample it in
this particular realization the third
bit in the second to last bit or
resample and then for those bits I then
put it I decide again whether it's going
to be 1 or 0 and here it happened to
turn out to be this so it happened this
0 happened to be stay as ero afters we
randomized well this one happened to a
switch to a 0 ok
any questions okay so now we're going to
get to the notion of noise sensitivity
the question Joyce enca tivity simply
asked is f of X and f of X epsilon
you've just proved it a little bit you'd
10 is f of X and f of X 0 X epsilon is
it are they very likely to be the same
so this would be high correlation or are
they almost independent which would be
low correlation so that's the question
and the answer is of course it depends
so if of course if you fix n and you fix
the boolean function f then of course if
epsilon is extremely small of course f
in at FX + f of X epsilon are very
likely to be the same because if epsilon
is very small even X and X epsilon are
going to be the same as very high
probability and so f of X and F X
epsilon will be the same without public
so the right way to ask the question is
you should think of epsilon is
completely fixed but very small and then
you take end to be very large and once
you formulate the question like that you
it's sort of you naturally come up with
the following ocean due to Benjamin
decline from that a sequence of boolean
functions FN is called noise sensitive
if so this is a definition and it's
supposed to correspond exactly to when f
of X and F X epsilon or independent and
so the right definition should be if for
any epsilon positive and this is I
formulated slightly different the usual
way but its equivalent but it will be I
want to do it this way so I look at the
problem I can do I look at the probably
that FN of the perturb sequences one
given FN of the original string is one
and if these were independent this would
just be of course the probability that
FN of x epsilon is one the probability
of that and so I call it noise sensitive
if the difference between these
approaches 0 as n goes to infinity for
any fixed value of epsilon so that's
what noise sensitivity means while it's
not not obvious it turns out that if
this quantity here approaches 0 for 1
value of epsilon it approaches 0 for all
values of that
so long so it doesn't matter what
epsilon you you use okay so let me give
you very quickly extremely quickly for
examples dictator so FN x is just x 1
it's pretty obvious that this is not
noise sensitive for any p because the
first bit will very unlikely to be
resample so this is not noise sensitive
and in fact it's something which is
called noise stable which i might
mention at the end of the talk the
parity function i sum up the bits mod 2
and think of pn being a half in this
case it's going to be it's not hard to
see its noise it'll be noise sensitive
because very likely one of these bits
will be resample then everything gets
mixed up and so this is noise sensitive
the majority function might take a
little extra thought so the majority
functions of function which is it's one
if there's more ones and zeros and
imagine n is odd so this is a nice but
probably f1 is is a half and it it turns
out this one is also this is not noise
sensitive think if you want for P being
a half so it if the original sequence
has more ones and zeros and epsilon
small the after you perturb things it's
also going to be likely to be one and
this is turns off also be something
which is called noise stable which I'm
not describing at this point I've
mentioned another example just because
it comes up later this if we take the
erdos-renyi random graph model where p
is taken to be a half what we want to do
is we want to ask is there a big clique
now it turns out if you look at the size
of the biggest clique clique and look at
its distribution for most values of n
it's extremely concentrated on one value
this the largest click is going to be
this number with probability close to 1
and that number is something going to be
like to log base two of n minus 2 log 2
of n but nonetheless they'll be
occasional values of n where in fact the
the distribution of the largest click is
non-degenerate will be one of two values
each with some non-trivial probability
when that occurs you have an interesting
boolean function I mean the boolean
function of course just the indicator
function of say that the the clique is
the larger size so occasionally you can
get an interesting event or boolean
function here and then in this case it
turns out to be noise sensitive that ok
any questions ok now I just want to do
one slide on percolation I'm not gonna
be discussing any percolation other than
the top but this is such a nice example
where noise sensitivity percolation come
together I wanted to address one slide
to this so in this case we have an N by
n box in the gate in the hexagonal grid
and z2 and we color the save the blacks
will be one and the whites will be zero
so those are our sequence of n bits or
in fact if it's an N by n box there'll
be about N squared bits and the as I
said p is a half in the event we're
going to look at is the following of
course the boolean function is the same
as it is an event the event we're going
to look at is is there a crossing from
the left side to the right using the
black black hexagons so in this
particular case we see there is a
crossing of black crossing and that's
the boolean function and so you can ask
is this noise sensitive so in other
words if we had a crossing beforehand
red now becomes black and now we do this
epsilon noise now notice when we do this
epsilon noise I'm REE randomizing
epsilon percent of the bit so look if
you look at the configuration it looks
almost the same I've only changed a few
of these few of these hexagons but the
Epsilon's fixed system very large and
you can ask well is that the case if I
had this crossing before and I epsilon
noise it I'm am I going to still have a
crossing and or is it these become
independent which means noise
sensitivity and this was one of the main
results proved in the original benjamini
kailash rom pay for noise sensitivity
that the percolation crossings are noise
sensitive let me just make a quick
common in with noise sensitivity in
general and in particular noi
sensitivity for the percolation
crossings you can ask about quantitative
noise sensitivity and what quantitative
noise sensitivity means is you don't fix
epsilon but you in fact let epsilon to
even go to zero with n now if epsilon
goes to zero to quickly within then
things aren't going to then the
configurations will look too much alike
in you won't get this asymptotic
independence but maybe the epsilon and
can go to zero sort of it's some slower
rate you still get the asymptotic
independence and if you're asking the
question how quickly can epsilon and go
to zero but I still get this asymptotic
independence then you're asking you're
you're discussing quantitative noise
sensitivity issues and it turns out the
there you can do this here and it's
related critical exponents and the if
you're interested in reading i mentioned
that christoph garb on and i have
lecture notes on this and allah a large
part of it is about percolation ok
that's the end of the percolation so one
of the concepts that comes up in the if
you're interested in noise sensitivity
is another concept in about boolean
functions which is already risen in a
number of Fox here is the notion of PIP
influences so that's plays a key role
here so we have pivot ality and
influence and so as you've probably all
seen for a boolean function f the event
that I is pivotal is simply the event
that if you to change the ice bit then
the output function changes its value
that happens we say I is pivotal and
then if you talk about the probability
that I is pivotal that's what we call
the influence the influence of the ice
pit I sub i correspond the I fit this is
the probability that I is pivotal this
is also called the bands bonds off
Penrose index and you might wonder which
Penrose is it so a lot of us might know
Matthew Penrose the probable asst so
it's Matthew pen roses grandfather
Lionel Penrose okay
yeah the knives famous is his uncle and
it says the uncle father great
mathematician yeah I think he did like
everything you know back then they did
everything I think he did it was pot
political science some medicine use a
chess player I know that's not a were
not as narrow as we are today okay so
very quickly is it so the dictator
function these are just is of course the
influence of the first fits one if the
terms at all the other influences are
zero the parity function of course all
the influences are one because if you
change any bit the output changes the
majority function is e all is if you had
is the only first slightly interesting
one is the what's the probability of say
the first bit being pivotal whoa of
course the first bit can only change the
outcome of the election if there's a
complete tie among all the other bits
and the probably that that's a tie is 4
to 1 over square root of N and where you
can this click containment you can
complete compute the influences but we I
don't we won't worry about that now okay
so if you're interested in noise
sensitivity even if you are not
interested in influences you should be
interested in influences because it's
related to the noise sensitivity so
influences are very relative for noise
sensitivity so the one of the main
results in the benjamina klystron pay
paper is if P n is constant then if you
take the sum of the squares of the
influences you take all the influence of
all the bits square them all and add
them up if this sum goes to 0 then the
sequence is noise sensitive so the
parity function doesn't so you could ask
is that what happens about the converse
that the parity function shows us can
this condition above is not in fact
necessary because the parity functions
noise sensitive in fact it's the most
noise sensitive function but the
influence are all one so the converse is
not true however the converse is true
for
large class of boolean functions namely
all the monotone functions so that this
condition above is necessary for
monotone increasing functions again for
constant P and this point I want to
think of pianist constant doesn't depend
upon n okay so this gives you a nice
that gives you a very nice it gives you
a for monitoring functions and the rest
of the talk in fact I'm only going to be
dealing with monotone functions then
this gives you a necessary and
sufficient condition for noise
sensitivity for a constant level of
noise a constant level p which is
constant notice the majority functions
what happens to that I already told you
it was not noise sensitive all right
yeah I told you that was not not noise
sensitive and if you plug this into the
thing what happens the influences were 1
over square root of n you square that
you get 1 over N I sum them up I get one
and so in some sense the sum just barely
doesn't go to 0 in the sense that it
doesn't go to infinity so the majority
functions just miss satisfying that this
sum goes to 0 and it turns out the
majority functions an extreme example in
a lot of respects in in this theory okay
and the proof of this uses for analysis
and hyper contractivity so the hyper
contractivity corresponds to
inequalities which is the theme of the
conference so things fit in okay so now
those results are for p being constant
now we're interested that okay now if
we're interested in the g the random
graph model or p won't be constant is n
varies so let me say a couple words
about the small p problem so first that
the be cast vks benjamina klystron
theorem it becomes false when P n
approaches zero one simple example you
could take is I could take the
erdos-renyi random graph model ah where
my my function is simply containing a k
4 so does the graph contain a click on
four points tonight's boolean function
if I take my pee
to be n to the minus two thirds that's
the correct fee to take so that the this
event is non-degenerate and then it then
this is clearly not noise sensitive
because if i have a que for sitting
there and then i apply the noise that k
for is going to be sitting there after I
do the noise because those tet six edges
won't be killed but it turns out the
condition on the previous slide the sum
of the squared influences goes to zero
so for varying p there's results by
keller and Kindler they have they have a
result which extends the bks theorem and
it says it in certain cases into the
ravine pn equaling n to the minus little
o of 1 so it that it can't go to you can
go to 0 you know maybe like 1 over log n
but it can't go like a polynomial O yeah
yeah I know yeah it's an exercise so it
turns out when you complete yeah no I
know you're right yeah yeah this away
not sign an exercise for you but so you
if you plug in the influences and
computed this the Sun won't go to zero
okay uh so however the kitten in the
cases in many cases this critical value
of PN for the model you're looking at it
turns it's going to be polynomial II
small in the variables and so what are
some examples we might be thinking about
going back the erdos-renyi model
connectivity you might ask for
connectivity of this random graph model
you do the random graph is the graph
connected on all on the n vertices so it
turns out the right value of P to take
for this particular property is log n
over N at that level log n over n the
probably being connected stays bounded
away from 0 and 1 as n goes to infinity
and they're even turns out to be sort of
a very sharp threshold if you replace
log n by log n plus a million then for
even for an very large in fact the
probability of being connected is very
hi but anyway this is sort of where the
transitions occurring so this is this is
it a level in a polynomial II small like
1 over N okay so that might be one you'd
be interested in you could ask if that's
noise-sensitive will be coming back to
things like this later another one is
hamiltonicity hamiltonicity means the
graph contains a Hamiltonian cycle
that's simply a cycle that goes through
all the vertices so if so you can ask
does your graph have a Hamiltonian cycle
in it and it turns out the correct value
of P to study that problem turns out to
be log n plus double log n over N at
this particular value of P the
probability of having this Hamlet own
cycle this bet is bounded away from 0
and 1 so and another one is the giant
component which if you do p equals 1
over n that sort of the exact if you
take P to BC over n there's something
very happening interesting happen when C
is one and you suddenly get this giant
component and we'll come back to
something that occurs there that I don't
think I was going to mention something
but I don't I won't worry about this
last slide which begins don't worry so
let's get that ok so uh ok so now I'm
going to start to gut move into this
notion of strong noise sensitivity so
and so this is witnesses and strong
noise sensitivity so now our functions
are going to be filmed to be monotone
you could maybe define this for non Mon
it's on functions but it's not very
natural ok so I oh what a one-witness or
what some people might call a one
certificate or some people might be
called a min term it's a minimal is
given a boolean function it's a minimal
subset of the variables with the
property that if I put a one if those
did at those bits then the function is
guaranteed to be one even if I put all
zeros in the other bits and that this
set is minimal with respect to that
property so it's a set which if I put
one Sarah's gerund a few to one but if I
take any subset and put all ones I'm not
guarantee to be one okay that's what a
one-witness is so
and so for example if the grout if the
property is that the graph is connected
what would be a one-witness is set of
edges where you know the graph is
connected that of course be exactly a
spanning tree of the graph that would
that would then the that's exactly a
one-witness okay so we let script one
denote the set of one witnesses of some
boolean function and similarly w sub 0
then 0 0 the set of 0 witnesses okay so
it says it says it's zero witnesses
those guys were if i were to put 0 at
those places i would be guaranteed the
function is 0 okay so noise sensitivity
ok so in store noise sensitivity so I
just recall exactly the definition we
had of noise sensitivity said its noise
sensitivity well with respect you always
have this the PM that's given to you if
for every epsilon positive when I look
at the probability that FN at the
perturbed sequences one given FN at the
original sequences one that conditional
probability and i subtract off the
unconditioned probably this goes to 0 ok
that's the notion of noise sensitivity
now if we look what does it mean FN of x
is 1 if you know FN of x is 1 the only
way FN of x can be one there has to be
some witness which is all ones ok so so
oh but that's ok no one witness is just
the set of variables with the part that
if I were to put one's there the gap the
function would be one so if FN of x is
one there's going to be some witness
which is all ones and imagine yourself
in a situation where all the one
witnesses in fact look the same there's
a lot of symmetry in your problem all
the witnesses the same like containing a
clique in a graph all the cliques work
the same so now if you had if you have
if you were in that situation all the
witnesses look the same and I told you
FN of x is 1 so that's sort of telling
you are there's some witness one
witnesses which is one since it's you
don't know which one it is sort of like
conditioning on a just sort of like
conditioner
particular witness being one okay so so
so you won you you might be a trick
people into thinking this that it's
basically conditioning just on some
witness being one and so independent
whether that's true or not if it worked
true then the second definition would be
the same is the first step in here so a
sequence of boolean function is called
one strongly noise-sensitive if well in
the in the case let's say where you all
the witnesses were the same basically
instead of condition FN of x being one I
take a particular one witness and I
condition it to be one so I just take a
one-witness ID condition being one and
then I asked now after I do the
perturbation what's the probability FN
of after do the perturbation what's the
probably being one and is it the case
that this conditioning in the limit they
become essentially independent so if I
then subtract off the unconditioned
probability this goes to zero and if
this occurs i call it strong noise
sensitive now of course in a lot of
cases the one witnesses might not be
playing the same role they might not all
have the same structure so I'll take a
maximum of this conditional probability
overall though the one witnesses and if
this occurs i call it strongly noise
sensitive ok any comment sir
okay so okay so the max is of course
stronger obviously so if you can prove
theorems which is one strong then you
get a stronger thing with this
definition of course if we if you prove
something's not one strong you can start
asking other things but in a lot and a
lot of situations you might have
symmetry anyway like a lot of examples
will describing then of course it
doesn't matter but and there's other
other there's other reasonable
definitions one might use this is
somehow a clean one but you could take a
weaker one clear is in the eye of the
beholder you can ask me if it's true is
it right that's the hit okay yeah so the
answer the question will be on the next
slide almost so then we have the notion
of 0 strong noise sensitivity which is
just the obviously the complete opposite
I condition on a zero witness being 0
and ask how that affects things okay ah
strong noise sensitivity implies noise
sensitive but the converse turns out not
to be true and this is even true even if
you start asking quantitative questions
I said you can ask about quantitative
questions for noise sensitivity you can
also ask for quote the analogous
quantitative things for strong noise and
this implication works just as well I'm
not going to give the argument it but
it's it's a it's it's it's like a two
line argument it's quite easy to do
better so the notion of strong noise
sensitivity it's intimately connected to
the structure of the set of witnesses
you'll get yeah yeah you'll you'll get
one in very soon so this is claims there
so there first so there's also there's
an example which is strong one noise
sensitive but not strong zero we'll see
this in a moment and it's the point is
that the one witnesses for your boolean
function can have a very very different
structure than the zero witnesses sort
of very vaguely like in three sat
if this is a very vague thing like to
show you three sat is satisfiable I just
provide for you the variables if
something's not satisfiable like I can't
provide you in the same way the
information that it's not satisfied
soluble so so 10 can play a very
asymmetric role and that will happen
here and finally I'm going to say that's
the end okay so let me give you an
example now so the very enlightening
sample enlightening example is tribes
which is described on the top picture
here so you partition 1 through n into
blocks like this of each of these have
length log n minus log log n and I
simply look is there a block which is
all ones if there's a block with all
one's I say the function is 1 if there's
no such block I say the function is 0
okay so it says here right here let F be
one if some block is all ones okay what
are the one witnesses for this well
let's take the end to be a half here so
here's a one witness the ones in blue
this is a one-witness basically by the
way I described the boolean function
those are exactly the one witness is one
of these blocks what is a zero witness
look like obviously that have to give
you a 0 nica these this is a zero ennis
notice the one blot the one witnesses
are just simple next to each other
completely destroyed the zero witnesses
have very complicated overlap okay so in
an so it's easy to show that the
probably F is one is non-degenerate this
stays away from zero and one basically
because the number of blocks which are
one has a bit basically a Poisson
distribution in the limit this let me
quickly mention this example was of
interest since the influences turn out
to be log n over N as mentioned in the
original paper and they asked it in the
original paper is it the case that maybe
for every boolean function there's
always some variable whose influence is
order log n over N and that was showing
later on to be true by Khan client
lineal so this log n over n a sort of
often
for that question but that's not not so
related to the talk it's easy to see
this is noise sensitive it's also easy
to see that this is strong noise
sensitive strong one noise sensitive
this easily follows from the fact that
the one witnesses are pairwise disjoint
however one can show that the sequence
is not zero strong somehow when you the
effect of conditioning on a zero witness
to be 0 when you do this condition here
it has drastic effects much much more
drastic effects than when you condition
on a one witness and so it's it's not a
zero strong and this because you zero
what witnesses have pairwise overlap so
that almost gives your example just
switch ok so now let me start mentioning
some some some of the results so let me
mention some quantitative noise
sensitivity results for the erdos-renyi
random graph model so in this first
event we're going to be at p n equals 1
over n that's that's in the the the real
that's the real the most interesting
regime for the model because it's where
the largest component sort of become
size n to the two-thirds and the event
is we're going to ask in this random
graph is there a is there a a cycle of
length is there a cycle of length
contained between n to the one-third and
to end to the one-third so it turns out
that this event this particularly event
is noise sensitive and in fact it's one
strong noise sensitive and in fact
there's even a quantitative version of
this no no I just have yeah I'm just
dealing with 01 variables um ok so the
so the so this is the the quantitative
version if your epsilon n goes to even
if it goes to 0 as long as it stays if
it's much much bigger than n to the
minus one-third power
then you get this the thing that if I
condition on a particular one witness in
this case all the one witnesses are the
same condition on a one-witness I look
at the probability that FN of the
perturbed thing is one this and you
subtract the the unconditional
probability this is 0 of 1 it goes to 0
in the limit so you get asymptotic
independence in particular that's true
for fixed epsilon so this shows this one
strong noise sensitivity on the other
hand if you take epsilon to be much
smaller than n to the minus one-third
then you get a type of stability if the
original sequence is 1 then with
extremely high probability the perturbed
sequence will also have output 1 meaning
that what the cycle yeah you won't tell
this yeah it's trivial because this you
won't kill the cycle which is restore
one which is noise sensitivity not one
strong I have it but I haven't commented
on that yeah I haven't convincin that's
a good question so i might mention that
way at the end yeah but I we just asked
to provide one wishes noise sensitive
and not one strong yeah but okay but
then that's that turns out not we didn't
find this so easy to construct we
managed in the end you okay we'll get it
okay that doesn't work but well that
actually turns out to be another
interesting example which will see here
okay so and if if X epsilon and is
exactly one over on the one-third you
don't get either this behavior so you
you have the rate at which things are
happening now what's interesting is a
comment for this that this quantitative
result involving n to the minus
one-third this matches what's called the
critical window for this model so it's
not--it's its knowing that I don't think
I'm to go into this very much if you
happen to know what the critical window
is somehow
the the noise you add to the system for
you to get this noise sensitivity it has
to be enough noise to pull you outside
of what is called the critical window
for the model I don't think it's worth
going into details without it if those
words don't mean anything so I won't say
so much there and the this is all i'm
going to say about the argument its fate
it's based on some second moment
calculation it's based on some various
types of calculations that's that's what
we did is what we do for a living okay
hope that gives you a favor of it okay
so now let me go on to the next one so
at first this example might not look
might not look so interesting or but
they're dried but it's going to turn out
to be related to other things that might
sound more interesting so I'm going to
the boolean function I want to now on
look at is minimum degree at least k so
I do random graph and I 10 does every
vertex have that least K edges coming
out coming out of it it's a monotone
function that's the event I want to look
at it turns out that for the event
having at least K edges coming out every
point the correct value of P you should
take so that this probability is
non-degenerate is log n plus K minus 1
log log n over N and it turns out if you
look at this event degree at least K at
that PN it is noise sensitive and
moreover it's 0 strong noise sensitive
now even in this case we have you can
get you can get quantitative results and
here the epsilon the correct
quantitative regime is 1 over log n so
if you take epsilon to be much much
bigger than 1 over log in you get exact
sort of what we had the other slide but
now we're dealing with 0 so you can did
you take a zero witness you condition of
being zeroes and you ask how does that
affect the probability that they
function is zero after I do the
perturbation then you subtract the
unconditioned probability and it says
this goes to 20 so when you condition on
the zero witness this won't have any
that this will become asymptotically
independent of that and in particular
this gives you no ordinary noise
sensitivity if epsilon and is much less
than 1 over log n then you get this type
of stability if FN of x were 0
beforehand after you do the noise it
will still be 0 noda notice the the zero
witnesses ok ok well in a moment so
epson if epsilon n is of order 1 over
log in you get neither of these
behaviors ok so like this that discusses
for one second when when K is 0 ok is
one so I want to know minimum degree at
least one that's the saying no isolated
vertices now it's very easy it's the
witness what is a witness for of zip
zero witness zero witness just looks
like this I take one vertex I take all
the edges coming out and I and I and I
turn them in there and I just turn them
all off I say they're off then you're
guaranteed that this is a zero witness
you have an isolated point and this is
the only type of zero witness mission
Sharon ah the okay so okay so let me
give you the praise is a very easy but
let me mention the proof of this and the
consequences of this 0 strong accent as
sensitivity for minimum degree at least
K so the proof idea it's extremely
simplest first for establishing minimum
degree K 0 strong noise sensitive so
it's basically because of the following
at this point just take k to be 1 so we
want we want to talk about having an
isolated vertex recall the tribes
function over here there the tribes were
the all the one witnesses were destroyed
and this makes it very easy to be 11
strong and you have a similar type of
thing if you look at the zeros from then
our group minimum degree at least a or
if we think a minimum degree at least
one they're not going to be disjoint but
they're going to be awfully close to
being this joint and they'll be close
enough to being disjoint that basically
you can show very easily that you have
this zero strong noise sensitivity
because they're almost disjoint and then
you sort of do that and that's basically
the basically all you do is now why are
you interested in that it's because you
get consequences of things which our
priority might not have been obviously
noise sensitive so let's now go back to
the random graph model at pn being log n
over n and talk about connectivity let's
forget this containing a perfect match
thing so weak on it so connectivity is
you recall the pn being log n over n is
that's the exact correct pn to look at
and as a corollary you get that this is
noise sensitive and you even get that
you even get that it's quantitatively
noise sensitive at this rate 1 over log
n so why do you why do you get that and
I'm just going to say this in words the
reason being how different are the
events the event connectivity and no
isolated
vertices okay of course if you're
connected you don't have any isolated
vertices but it's also the case if you
don't have any vices isolated vertices U
hat you are most likely connected in
other words these two events are not the
same event but if you look at this the
symmetric complement of the events that
probability is going to 0 and wait what
connectivity no so let me let me get so
I'm going to comment on this so okay so
since the zero containing at least the
having degree at least 1 is 0 strong
then it's therefore the ordinary noise
sensitivity noise sensitive and because
it's asymptotically the same event as
connectivity you get that the
connectivity is noise sensitive and you
get the quantitative result but you
don't get these this strongness thing
this doesn't push through if you can
have events which are very close where
they're symmetric coming has probably
going to zero but the strong and things
don't carry it carry over so i'll
mention that in the next one so for
example you can do something as similar
with a Hamiltonian cycle so for hamilton
cycle is you'll recall the interesting
pn is log n plus log log n over n and
containing it Hamilton cycle this is
noise sensitive this is because Hamilton
cycle well if you have a Hamilton cycle
that means every vertex has degree at
least two but it turns out if every
vertex has a degree at least two that
more or less guarantees you have a
Hamilton nonito mean cycle in terms of
probability so Hamilton having a
Hamilton cycle is the same as
emphatically is having degree at least
two and so you get the noise sensitivity
but on the other hand Hamilton cycle is
not zero strong the structure of the
zero the zero witnesses for for the
having a degree at least two or very
have a very simple structure but the but
the the structure of the zero witnesses
for Hamilton cycle is much more
complicated and some of them were bad
that some of them are bad witnesses so
you actually don't get that ok
a difference between Max and the average
somehow it gets on average yeah yeah
exactly yeah so we we I mean so some
point we are he mentioned things like
this in the paper and sometimes we were
hesitating we ended up deciding we're
gonna take this is the formal definition
it in the end reham you can have other
definitions which are sufficient and
they're not as clean and so some of
these other things might exactly give
you this because the the the the typical
witnesses will be nicer witnesses yeah
yes uh I don't know if we end up check
my guess is it's not Joe strong but I
don't think we actually we check them
yeah that will stay yeah yeah okay so
the next event I want to look at is is
graph containment one of the things we
talked about earlier was containing a
click whether a graph contains a click
but you can start saying does it contain
a given graph so we've already seen the
event of click containment more
generally let hnb a graph on at most n
vertices and let FNB the indicator
function that your errors for any graph
contains H n so before we looked at hm
being a click of the appropriate size
log base two of n or whatever it was and
we asked is this event noise sensitive
so again we would mean that if I know
like it so you know whether a graph
contains hn to begin with and after I do
the tiny perturbation do these become
asymptotically independent well of
course if HN is a triangle for every n
obviously no you're just going to stay
so what should you what what should you
have what should you graph be doing in
order to have some chance maybe no p @ p
n in this point imagine pn is going to
be such that hn is non-degenerate so for
four triangles that strictly no
okay yep HSN is a union of log n
disjoint edges the answer is no so it's
not if the grass growing that doesn't
necessarily help you because having
login disjoin edges this is sort of
going to be like a majority function and
so it'll be stable so it turns out a
relevant thing is if the graph is
strictly balanced so a strictly balanced
graph is a graph with the property that
if you look at its edge vertex ratio
that's its larger than the edge vertex
ratio of all the smaller sub graphs and
one of the things is that if you take if
your graph hn is strictly balanced and
the number of edges in it is bigger than
one good much bigger than one meaning
it's growing but it's at most log n over
log log in to the one-half power then it
turns out that this function is noise
sensitive and in fact it's one strong
noise sensitive now you could ask how
sharpest is log in to the one-half we
don't know exactly but but it's not so
far so it turns out there's a sequence
of strictly balanced graphs hn with
Ellen being asymptotic to log n at where
the number of edges is a log N and it's
there strictly balance but you don't get
the you don't get the noise sensitivity
and what you can do is basically take
two triangles and a path between them of
size 3 halves log lambda then and where
your PN is lambda over N it turns out
this graph strictly balance but you
don't get the noise sensitivity so you
know of course it's a big gap the
Ottomans log in to the two-thirds who
knows that would be surprised if you
could figure it out do anyway okay so
let me in my last two in minutes or two
and a quarter minutes left let me
quickly very mention some differences
between noise sensitivity and strong
noise sensitivity one is you have this
dependence in noise sensitivity
noise sensitivity says this quantity is
asymptotically independent in ordinary
noise sensitivity and I mentioned this
doesn't depend on epsilon but it turns
out our definition of one strong noise
sensitivity it required that this thing
went 2-0 they become Assam togda an
event for every pot of value of epsilon
turns out that it whether this goes to
zero can depend upon epsilon so it can
be the case for large epsilon you get
asymptotic independence and for small
you don't you can create examples like
this so that's one way in which it's
different and the last slide so noise
stable means the following it basically
means if you take your noise to be very
very small then with very high
probability if you started off being one
the perturbations going to be one no
matter where in your sequence you are
now it turns out that on the other hand
assuming your functions are non
degenerate whenever you do some new ways
to the system the probability the
function gets change is always going to
be at least proportional to epsilon but
interestingly forget the three okay in
the three iterated majority this turns
out three of the majority is here it's
just you you make a three every tree you
put bits down here and you do majority
iteratively turns out this is not noise
sensitive and if you look at the this
probability of having a zero given a
witness is one sorry thank you it's not
strongly noise sensitive it's no it's
known to be sensitive then this thing is
epsilon over two turns out something
really weird there's a less able to say
something really weird in different
options with the five majority function
which is described here what happens is
something which cannot happen ordinary
noise sensitivity what happens is no
matter which epsilon you take even if
you take epsilon extremely close to one
lots of noise if you condition on a one
witness for the five majority and look
at the probability gets switched by the
perturbation is n goes to infinity this
is turns out to be equal to 0 we you
don't take a limit as epsilon goes to 0
it is for
level of noise you get extremely high
dependence so something very different
time with five and three majority and
this is sort of something like this
cannot happen in ordinary noise
sensitivity yeah but no no it's it's
even more note it's even it's it's not
it's even more stable than three
majority yeah but this to a bit i was
gonna give it then yeah right okay
thanks for your attention yes we do we
have one that are both 1 and 0 with
their site in the summer yeah Oh see ya
better talk in a while to make yeah but
yeah there's one and two we have another
paper another vision about the creation
so just a can you say something so we
know the third version is always
sensitive is usual
using a nothing birthday easy can you
say what are the initial states were for
which it's still stable like for the all
0 if all the exam or white yeah you know
this case right it's david can you
connect the eyes oh no I don't think you
could characterize I think that's
probably a hard [ __ ] I mean okay you can
make a lot of statements wait wait some
but not AI know how many interesting
statements you can make yeah yeah okay
the answer is I have no idea you create
you you can look at these conditional
probability write down a recurrence
relation you look at the fixed points it
just has it it the something which
before was something becomes a repelling
fixed point which for the three majority
was neither repelling the were
attracting but other than that I can I
don't know there's no good i know a good
explanation so he talks about me deeply
killed what about something like cake or
the property
okay i'm not that much in every race I
don't know that means cake or but it did
ya know
crime
a good question we've never thought
about that question from grasses they
could be non recoverable I don't think
nonce we color ability can be understood
he's not a cat position internet you can
make no precise between the structural
cells with this is that guarantees
you're given can we describe when you
get one strong in terms of the structure
of the witnesses no I mean I mean we
have some fields of what's causing
things but without this we don't have
any characterization that you can say in
terms of structural agencies but if some
of these theorems is it to do some of
these what you use the combinatorial
structure of the min terms so say
they're certain sizes and we know
distribution of them intersections so so
you could for some of these statements
you would
it's strongly
what I'm saying well so I don't know it
by its stronger but saying so I green
light for the minimum k you have a very
nice picture the witnesses but i know
but i'm not from which direction we want
to strengthen the fit things because if
you say what the other oh no idea i have
to think about it thank you for that
openwork arrested do you have an example
of sensitive function
quantitative freshman is necessary
speaking louder than
I mean if not something you say that
some point that the four cycles and oh
yeah the other ones it coincides yappin
yep there is an example of paper which
shows that this philosophy that the
noise how much know the noise
quantitative noise sensitivity is not
always governed by this lengths of the
of the critical window uh you know I
have to remember now if it's for the
shorter but there is one example where
they don't correspond but that you yeah
the way I could explain it separately